a suicide squad will feature a slew of
new to their silver screen faces and
we've got the scoop on who they are and
what they do
here's a breakdown of every new
character in the suicide squad roll call
when aegis elba's name first cropped up
in connection with the suicide squad it
was as a reported replacement for will
smith's deadshot
smith who appeared as a smart mouse to
assassin and david ayer's suicide squad
had to drop out of guns project due to
scheduling conflicts
warner brothers and dc entertainment
executives may have initially wanted to
have dead shot in the follow up no
matter what but it was confirmed that
elba wasn't going to take smith's spot
after all
instead he'd be playing an entirely
different character not yet seen on the
silver screen
dc fandom confirms that elba is playing
blood sport in the suicide squad
three different people have taken on the
bloodsport moniker in the dc
comics but elba is playing the original
robert dubois
who first appeared in print in superman
volume 2 number 4.
dubois suffers a mental breakdown when
he learns that because he was too scared
to fight
himself his brother took his place in
the vietnam war and
ended up permanently injured after one
of lex luthor's lackeys convinces dubois
that superman is a person he needs to
exact revenge upon
dubois takes on the name bloodsport and
starts murdering his way through
metropolis with kryptonite bullets
before he's ultimately defeated by
superman it's probably unlikely that
elba's bloodsport will experience his
exact arc in the suicide squad but
there's a chance that certain elements
of it will make their way into the
characterization
michael rocker who played yondu in the
first two films and the guardians of the
galaxy franchise has a plum role in the
suicide squad as brian derlin
a spoiled millionaire who moves to
gotham city in hopes of becoming a
vigilante much like batman
working under the name savant derlin is
turned away from vigilantism by batman
himself
this motivates savann to become a
professional blackmailer
going on to do such outrageous acts as
kidnapping black canary
and overthrowing the gotham mafia with
the help of huntress
at one point in the comics cervantes
even offered a place on the birds of
prey team
however the new 52 comics rebooted
savant in september 2011
and the version of the character seen in
that run is almost definitely the one
we're getting in the suicide squad
the recent comics depicts savant as an
extremely amoral and lethally effective
member of the suicide squad
polka dot man is a silly looking villain
who's originally an enemy of batman
born abner krill and originally known as
mr polkadot polkadot man made his print
debut in detective comics number 300.
polkadot man sent us his entire modus
operandi around spots and dots and acts
mostly as a low-level rogue who does all
he can to capture batman's attention
and prove he's just as clever and
capable as the beloved superhero though
his presence isn't as prominent as say
the joker
polka dot man still packs a punch thanks
to the powers his removable suit dots
give him such as
duds that transform into flying saucers
chainsaws and floating fists
a suicide squad's polka dot man will
likely have a fresh story
one focused more on his connections to
the titular crew for the role of polka
dot man the suicide squad snagged actor
david dasmulchin who
appeared in the dark knight as a former
arkham patient named thomas schiff
one of joker's goons who attempted to
murder the mayor it'll be interesting to
see what das mulchin brings to the table
in this new role
pitch perfect franchise breakouts and
german dj flulaborg will portray javelin
a german athlete who became a criminal
after leaving his sports career behind
javelin originally joins a suicide squad
after losing a fight against the green
lantern
and asks that all traces of his criminal
past be expunged upon him
becoming a member of the team he's a
solid addition to the suicide squad
using javelin-like weapons in combat and
he even participates in the war of the
gods dc comics crossover
ultimately that participation leads to
his death via his own javelin
a lot of fitting into your life's
pursuits
fans have known for a while that
portuguese actress daniella melchior
will portray ratcatcher in the suicide
squad now we know that melchior's
character is officially known as rat
catcher 2
in the suicide squad an interesting
moniker that suggests this rat catcher
could be a second iteration of the
exterminator turned villain
born otis flanagan ratcatcher used to
spend his time scurrying across gotham
city catching rats however his job as a
gotham city sanitation department rat
catcher
ends when he stabs a man to death and is
locked up for 10 years in the gotham
state penitentiary he then develops a
villainous alter-ego rat catcher holds
people prisoner in sewers
trains an army of rats to attack and
kill his enemies on command
and generally terrorizes gotham to hell
him back it doesn't seem like melchior
will be playing the otis flanagan
iteration of ratcatcher exactly but we
can guess that she's likely playing
another person who has taken on the rat
catcher name in otis's place
perhaps his daughter but much like the
definition of a rats it's unclear
right to outside myself yo but what if a
mouse goes outside does it become a rat
and if a rat is in the house is it a
mouse i ain't never seen no mouse
outside
that's because it's a rat fool where
suicide squad has killer croc
the suicide squad will have king shark
king shark is the son of the shark god
and possesses superhero durability
strength speed and stamina as well as
sonar capabilities
the ability to regenerate damaged body
tissue and super sharp
shark teeth comedian steve aggie will
voice king shark
who originally joins a suicide squad in
the comics when superboy teams up with
the crew to take down the silicon
dragons
a criminal cinder cup that was wreaking
havoc on the hawaiian islands
in the new 52 reboot of dc comics
continuity
king shark is one of the main characters
of the suicide squad and he's been a
familiar presence on the team ever since
suicide squad director david ayer
revealed in july 2016 that he wanted to
have king shark be on the team's lineup
however the cgi that would have been
required to bring king shark to life was
too much of an undertaking
so the film's creative team went with
killer croc instead
peacemaker first appeared as christopher
smith in fight in five number 40
and was a charlton comics character
prior to dc comics acquisition
of the company as the peacemaker name
suggests smith is a diplomat
so deeply committed to peacekeeping and
the pacifist cause that he's willing to
go so far as to kill those who reject
law and order
in the comics peacemaker has a
life-altering revelation about why he's
so opposed to war
and begins to believe that the spirits
of people he has murdered are living
inside his helmet
another character called mitchell black
took on the peacemaker mantle in the
1996 issue comic series the law
but fans will likely see the christopher
smith iteration on screen in the suicide
squad former wwe superstar john cena
who is continuing to prove his acting
prowess will play peacemaker
and he's got a pity one sentence
summation for those unfamiliar with the
character
be like a douchey captain america
language tdk seems to be a new name for
an old character
floyd belkin also known by the hilarious
moniker arm fall-off boy
and even splitter from time to time
debuting in december 1989
secret origins volume 2 number 46 arm
falloff boy is based on a fan created
parody character that artist kurt swann
and writer gerard jones saw and totally
dug
armed fall-off boy possesses a
giggle-inducing ability to tear off his
own limbs and use them as blunt force
weapons
basically he embodies the threats i'll
rip your arms off and beat you to death
with them
except he's using his own arms to do the
maiming and murdering
in the comics he's mostly been
associated with the legion of
superheroes
which didn't exactly welcome him with
open um
nathan fillion will play tdk in the
suicide squad and with his background in
comedy
particularly his role as captain hammer
in dr horrible's sing-along blog
we can't think of a better person for
the part four different people have
utilized the name thinker to carry out
their supervillain tasks within the
pages of dc comics the suicide squad
will most likely feature the original
thinker
clifford devoe a failed lawyer who used
technologically powered telekinesis and
a device called the thinking cap to
become a master criminal
over the years he's bounced around the
dc universe although he's primarily been
a flash villain while on a mission with
the suicide squad in doom patrol and the
suicide squad special
the thinker was killed by weasel another
character appearing in the suicide squad
so we wouldn't hedge our bets on the two
getting along in the film the new 52
storyline forever evil saw the thinker
sent to bel reeve penitentiary where the
suicide squad is based and aligned
himself with the crime syndicate of
america
former doctor who star peter capaldi
will play the thinker in the upcoming
movie
best known for his work on saturday
night live pete davidson is taking on a
killer new role in the suicide squad
blackguard an enforcer for a crime
syndicate known as the a thousand
blackguard was once an everyday criminal
named richard hurts
before he joined the organization yes
that's really his name
after escaping death at the hands of his
fellow 1 thousand members blackguard
teams with the suicide squad on a
mission to kill high-ranking members of
a corporation
unfortunately for blackguard things
don't end well wade eileen a general and
suicide squad member with superhuman
abilities and regenerative powers
kills blackguard by squeezing his head
off it's a shame he wasn't more
headstrong
you'll never be the head of a major
corporation okay that'll do
okay the new mutants and predators
actress alicia braga will portray a
character by the name of zelsoria and
the suicide squad
not much concrete information is known
about solsoria
though the popular theory is that her
name is actually sol soria
a legitimate first and last name rather
than a super villain moniker
but regardless of name formatting
technicalities we're guessing that
braga's character could be a gender-bent
version of juan sauria as no such
character
named solsoria or solstoria exists in
the dc comics canon
as with many other recruits juan sroyer
was a common criminal before joining the
suicide squad in the comics he starts
out wanting to become a superhero
injecting himself with nanites to get
superpowers but things don't go as
planned
sorya auditions for the justice league
gets denied robs the bank gets sent to
bel reeve penitentiary
and is drafted into the suicide squad
he's treated pretty poorly
but it's all for a purpose an alien the
squad must defeat thrives on positivity
and sauria's negativity is what weakens
it keeping up with tradition
james gunn cast his brother in the
suicide squad sean gunn previously
played craiglin in guardians of the
galaxy and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 as well as
provided the motion capture for rocket
and he'll portray weasel in gun's newest
comic book movie
weasel begins his story on the pages of
1985's the fury of firestorm number 35.
in the 1960s a law student named john
monroe
was generally having a terrible time
despite being intelligent enough to get
into stanford university
his peers incessant taunting ultimately
pushes monroe to commit murder decades
later
adopting the name they call him weasel
as his alter ego moniker
while on a mission with a suicide squad
weasel kills the thinker
but the thinker's mind-enhancing cap
retains enough of its former owner's
mind to then force rick flag into
killing weasel like we said earlier it
doesn't seem like the thinker and weasel
will be lifelong friends in the film
possessing the powers of super strength
and stamina mongal is an
extraterrestrial warlord whose father
mongol the elder is the ruler of the
galaxy traversing slave holding
satellite war world
in one noteworthy appearance mongal
meets superman and brings him into the
warlord ship
fighting against him alongside her twin
brother mongol the younger
of course no sibling dynamic is perfect
and she eventually gets decapitated by
her brother
during a fight in green lantern volume 4
number 8
in the suicide squad expert martial
artist mei linga
who performs stunts in 2017's wonder
woman will bring mongal to life
the suicide squad hits theaters on
august 6th 2021.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
upcoming comic book movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one